head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
from The Verge ah yes the verge of all
websites they're a lefty website Twitter
tells advertisers that user growth is at
an all time at all time highs under Elon
Musk and then they add but will that be
enough for advertisers to come back yeah
it's it's pointless you don't need to
ask that question
since musk's takeover Twitter's
monetizable daily users has a growth has
accelerated to more than 20 percent
while Twitter's largest market the US is
growing even more quickly according to
an internal fact obtained by The Verge
that was shared with Twitter's uh sales
team on Monday all right that's the news
right there but this is why it's
important because right now we are
seeing a bunch of leftists these these
people who go on Twitter and just scream
all day they're getting banned Kathy
Griffin's gone this guy yeah Rich Summer
is gone Sarah Silverman backed down I
love this these people who are like
screw you Elon I'll do whatever I want
well a bunch of them went nuts Ethan
Klein Kathy Griffin for instance defied
warnings and impersonated Elon Musk with
a verification badge which has always
been against the rules and they're gone
bye-bye you're out of the conversation
now look
that's not the end of their careers of
course I mean Kathy Griffin maybe she
had nothing left to begin with nobody
wants to hire her all she really had was
her Twitter but you know Ethan he hosts
a podcast so he'll be able to keep
working he's just out of the Twitter
space Sarah Silverman she posted that
she was locked out of her account and
then quickly obeyed the rules and then
started saying what Elon Musk was doing
if true would actually be very very
amazing so I find this to be quite
hilarious that uh all their huffing and
puffing it's it's not working in fact
Elon Musk taking over has made Twitter
bigger better yeah by the way Elon just
tweeted a couple of minutes ago quote
Twitter usage is at an all-time high LOL
and then goes on in a sub tweet saying I
just hope the servers don't melt now a
lot of people are bringing up the
controversy when it comes to the Banning
of a lot of these celebrities who again
didn't didn't follow the rules were
warned and they still decided to kind of
push the limits here but at the end of
the day I definitely disagree with Kathy
Griffin I definitely disagree with h3h3
but at the end of the day I hope there
is some Redemption for these individuals
but some people are are thinking that
this is going to be a larger strategy
when it comes to bringing back a lot of
different people so other people are
saying that this could be potentially 4D
chess as a way to bring back the
unbanned people and not have as much
controversy and try to appease some
people by saying you know what I'll
bring back H through H3 but also so does
Alex Jones you know I'll bring back
Kathy Griffin But but so will of course
the Babylon be and then of course have a
have a kind of concerted strategic
effort on Banning people I think that's
what might be happening here yeah I mean
musk clearly wants to bring all these
people back on the platform he clearly
wants Babylon B and all these guys back
he's just gonna like figure out how to
do it to not lose everybody and I think
that he's not going to lose everybody I
think advertisers are going to jump back
on they're going to make a ton of money
this way advertisers don't care we know
they don't care it's obvious they don't
care during pride month when they have
like all their big flags and they have
trans everything and they're super
stoked about that all over the
anglosphere and then you look at their
advertising in Saudi Arabia it's just
black and white yeah no Pride anywhere
you know they don't care they just want
to go where the money is and honestly
that is what they should be doing they
should be accountable to their
shareholders and that's what they should
do No Quarter
No Quarter for these leftists on Twitter
no look look if you come today put them
all on if you come to me oh so Sargon uh
Carl Benjamin gets banned and they all
say well he broke the rules he deserves
to be banned and it's like he got banned
for uh sarcastically insulting white
supremacists or neo-nazis or whatever he
was calling them a racial slur this is
Twitter so not the YouTube thing he was
calling them let's say anti-semitic sir
and I I could be wrong it's been a long
time but his his point was like he was
calling them what they hated as a way to
like demean them because he doesn't like
that kind of stuff they banned him he's
leftists then I'll say good riddance
good good good and so they're okay with
censorship they don't agree with free
speech now that Elon Musk is in charge
and saying here are the rules and
they're whining and complaining there is
absolutely no way I will defend people
think about how mean it would be to
actually try and get them back on the
platform that means they come out and
say I believe in these values and then I
go no no I'm going to reject your values
and apply different values to you no no
no no no no they don't want free speech
I will not defend their free speech
that's exactly what they want and what
they believe in so that means permanent
bands for all of these people Ethan
Klein Kathy Griffin don't care goodbye
Ethan Klein has praised cancel culture
he's praised Bannings before Kathy
Griffin of course okay then guys live by
you reap what you've sown yeah
I disagree to that too because the thing
is like the reason you have values isn't
because you want you know you have
values because you hold them across the
board for everybody you don't have you
don't apply your values uh you know
based on what the other people believe
it's like if somebody believes in
euthanasia and you're a doctor and you
don't believe in euthanasia you're not
going to help if if there's a bunch of
houses and we all agree okay if a house
starts on fire we will all come together
to help with the fire out and rebuild
the home for you because we're in this
together and then a fire starts and one
guy sits back laughing and we're like
hey are you gonna help us like no I
don't care it's good the fire's burning
and I'll be like okay dude whatever then
one day his house on Fridays help help
my house is on fire I'm gonna sit back
and be like bro you ain't getting
anything from me I'm not gonna sit here
and give give all of my good will to
people who exploit it now yeah that
means your about your values don't mean
anything it absolutely does it
absolutely does we've had this
conversation quite a bit about defending
free speech and for a long time I said
well you know what when when these
people advocate for the destruction
action of the public discourse we must
still defend their free speech no no no
no no when someone comes and says I
don't like what you said I don't want
you to say it and we argue about it that
that's that's that's fine but if someone
is actively destroying everything yeah
I'm not going to defend them they they
agree they believe in this they agree
with it you see my point I see your
point there was a period where
you know on this show and on other shows
we've talked about it's like no no no
you know I know these people they they
add no because what ends up happening is
every single time these people advocate
for things to get worse and they do and
then what did we keep doing put it
sitting down crossing our lives like no
no we have to be fair Rick Santorum came
on the show and said we can't impeach
Joe Biden we have to be fair and it's
like dude the guy committed crimes he's
like we don't play those games I am sick
of this I am done with it I believe in
free speech for people who agree and
with free speech if if you if you
believe I should have a right to speak
and you should have right to speak then
I will stop anyone from censoring you
because you are actively participating
and making things better but if you're
the arsonist go around burning down
houses then I Say No Quarter for you get
that out these are destructive people
who are burning everything down what if
the Fire gets too crazy and it affects
your house that's another analogy here
and and I and I do believe uh Biden
should be absolutely impeached and I
absolutely disagree with everything
thing I think I think some of their
behavior was absolutely disgusting
especially Kathy Griffin with the the
Trump mask the Trump head that was
absolutely uh just immoral issue yeah
the issue is they were actively getting
people banned and now when when the
rules are applied to them and get this
Elon changed the rules for these people
that also pissed me off the rules have
always been if you're verified you
cannot impersonate people what did Elon
say I'm changing the rules for all of
these unhinged leftists you're now
allowed to do it so long as you put
parody in your name and they still
wouldn't do it so they got banned these
are these are this is not so much even
about the analogy of people of someone
refusing to help with with you know my
house is on fire and he won't help no no
this is the guy who set the fire these
are people who went around actively
attacking the right of speech if that is
your principles I say you live by them
and I'm not going to defend you Kathy
Griffin wants to post a picture for what
Trump said I will defend her right when
they try to censor him she actively
encourages censorship I'm going to say
you live by the sword congratulations I
think everyone deserves a Road to
Redemption I totally agree I I think you
know they should be able to be be able
to be a part of the conversations they
should of course not be permanently
banned from ever being on a platform
that is a major communication Highway
that we should understand where their
voices are coming from in order to
battle their bad ideas because if we
just shun them to the side they're going
to grow in Fester I agree I get Megan
Murphy back on the platform yeah I I
agree however I will not in any way lift
a single finger to help them that's it
you know I'm listening to this I agree
with both of your points like I see
where you're coming from and I see where
you're coming from I'm gonna need like a
couple days to think about this because
you both make great points it's um do
you think there's any chance that Ethan
could come around based on this
experience or you think he's too
stubborn one more time sorry um could
Ethan come around on the idea of free
speech based on this experience could
this be eye-opening for him perhaps
um he praised cancel culture so whenever
whenever negative things are applied to
him he talks about how he's an advocate
for free speech when bad things happen
other people he talks about how you're
being held to certain standards and
facing consequences it's nonsense it's
hypocrisy so look well he's smart enough
guy to become successful right so maybe
he'll come around I'd be interested to
see if he has a different perspective
after this and he's made videos about me
by the way and I've never minded that
but I'd be curious to see if he comes
around based on this could be a teacher
I I doubt it he's saying uh Elon Musk
killed comedy dude broke the rules
defied the warnings broke the rules
again and now he's yeah it's a stunt but
I'll tell you the way I see this is
we're part of a big Community we agree
with the principle of free speech people
like this have lied cheated and stolen
their way to gain followers and gain
power their principles Flicker and blow
with the wind and it is completely
meaningless what they say so when they
come out now and say no no I'm for free
speech I'll be like listen I'm going to
hold you to the standards you asked me
to hold you to if someone if if somebody
was in my house and they kept smashing
things I would kick them out but then
but you're making them homeless you're
making them so what you were smashing
things up I don't want people to be
homeless I think people you know should
should have a chance but at a certain
point someone is so destructive chaotic
that you just say I'm not doing it if
Kathy Griffin got banned for just the
Trump head I'd be like no no no no no I
I I it's that's a really really
dangerous path to go with that kind of
art but I don't think we should be
banning that the difference here is
these are people who actively fight
against free speech and I'm at the point
where I'm like yo I'm not gonna let
arsonists in my house if we're all in
agreement that we shouldn't commit arson
we're good you can make a campfire
you're not doing arson you go to my
house start setting fires I'm not going
to sit here and be like nah it's all
right I believe in the people have a
right to to be warm it's like no that's
totally different there's a difference
it's just look I don't know about that
analogy I mean I don't I don't know
there's a lot of analogies here that we
could interpret in many different ways
you sit back and let people constantly
smack you in the face
and then when you say stop they go
They're going around punching people
another analogy for you and then you
just say like well I don't believe in
violence so we're gonna let him keep
doing it it's like no way dude well
that's the password you arrest them
pacifist view as if everybody's
attacking you you don't attack but words
aren't violent so so listen by all means
I thank Ethan and Kathy Griffin have a
right to speech I think that them
getting banned was actually kind of dumb
Elon should just lock their accounts
until they change it and then lock it
again until they change it as if you
can't and they take away the
verification badge another thing can do
is if you change your name and parody
someone your icon changes to a Jester
cap permanently so if Kathy Griffin
wants to parody Elon she gets a
permanent gesture cap however I will not
advocate for nor lift a finger for these
people to get their accounts back or
just put a notice underneath their
profile hey guys these guys impersonate
other individuals be careful if they
might be scamming yourself or something
like that yeah yeah or something like
that so they have the candidate tag put
a parity tag under their name the first
time they do it and forever that's it so
do you feel that it should be
permanently banned or that they should
do that other solution that you said I
think if you change your profile to
impersonate someone without labeling it
parity they should first lock your
account and say as a verified account
you can impersonate change your profile
picture and your name or add parity to
your account and apply the gesture icon
and then if you say no you can go back
to being your regular verified self if
you then keep doing it then they then
Twitter forcibly puts the parity under
your name permanently and a gesture icon
but there's nothing wrong with that if
you're an actual comedy account I
thought that was a great suggestion so
do you think that they should be left
banned or do the suggestion that you
said there so Justin I said but I'm I'm
I will never if I ever see Elon Musk not
a single word will be muttered of these
people in any way to bring their
accounts back I'm not going to do it I'm
not going to advocate for arsonists to
be restored do I think they deserve free
speech Yes will I defend anybody who
flies for free speech Yes but I'm done
letting arsonists run amok and then
acting like oh I'll say it again when
Rick Santorum said we can't impeach Joe
Biden because we we are better than that
I'm like dude they are running rough
shot over you right now they have
arrested and charged a bunch of
pro-lifers meanwhile right now there are
protesters at Amy Coney Barrett's house
maybe not right now but in the past day
or so there's there's a clear problem of
double standards here and I'm not going
to sit back and just be like well you
know I am I'm going to consistently
apply my values to evil people who are
burning things out hey comparing uh
someone or someone's argument to a Rick
Santorum argument is a low blow first of
all that's not fair he's is not a man of
the people and I definitely disagree
with him
um I don't know he's a very weird
politician but but again Main Line
middle of the road I I think again the
criticism of him is absolutely fair I
don't I don't know I don't think it
could be attributed to this larger
conversation thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time